[hudba]
[potlesk]
stále leodais byl nahrán do
Feodosia v okupovaném Rusku
náklad na ukrajinský Krym schválením
ambasády pocházejí z těch okupovaných Ruskem
území v Záporoží a Chersonské oblasti
[hudba]
byla koupena nová Lada za to, co je v lidech
říká se jim hroby, říká to otec
Alexey snil přesně o Bílém útoku
jde poprvé na hřbitov
[hudba]
zazněla slova podpory Ukrajincům
herečka Angelina Jolie Jennifer
Aniston Penelope Cruz Sarah Jessica
Parker Jessicy Chastainové je držitelkou Oscara
herec Robert De Niro Elijah Wood a Hugh
Lori, která je pánem slovy a kdo činy
Vyšel Oscar Španěl Javier Bardem
protiruský protest prvního dne
války en Reynolds a Blake krásné
otevřel sbírku pro Ukrajince
uprchlíkům je slíbeno zdvojnásobení všech
poskytnutý dar
[hudba]
[potlesk]